[SPEAKER_00]: Global progress relied upon a predictable multilateral framework that was rooted in the belief that open borders, integrated trade, and shared governance would foster universal prosperity.
[SPEAKER_00]: Today, that foundation is under unprecedented strain, to say the least.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are witnessing an era that's defined by geopolitical rivalries, trade decoupling, and escalating conflicts that are destroying countless lives, and also costing the global economy trillions of dollars.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are in an era of weapon rearmament.
[SPEAKER_00]: What we really need is moral
[SPEAKER_00]: and spiritual realignment.
[SPEAKER_00]: For Africa, these disruptions represent immediate socioeconomic challenges.
[SPEAKER_00]: While the continent's annual growth remains resilient, projected at a cautious 4.2%, it continues to be constrained by tight external credit markets, fractured supply chains,
[SPEAKER_00]: and global inflation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Compounding this challenge, traditional frameworks of multilateral assistance are also receding, refueling at UNDP.
[SPEAKER_00]: Official development assistance is declining, as well the nations increasingly prioritize domestic concerns, leaving a continent like Africa to navigate a staggering
[SPEAKER_00]: $1.3 trillion of annual development financing gap.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, this weakening of traditional multilateralism will not dictate Africa's future.
[SPEAKER_00]: On the contrary, it has accelerated the continent's sense of self-reliance.
[SPEAKER_00]: The era of relying on foreign development is over.
[SPEAKER_00]: and the era of genuine African agency has arrived.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are no longer waiting for the global financial architecture to reform itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Instead, I think Africa is establishing its own structural foundations to accelerate the UN sustainable development goals, but also the achievement of Agenda 2063.
[SPEAKER_00]: As the world retreats from multilateralism and everything that validates our common humanity, Africa is unveiling the world's largest trading bloc, the African Continental Free Trade Area.
[SPEAKER_00]: This arrangement has transitioned from a legal framework into an active integration engine by harmonizing customs protocols
[SPEAKER_00]: synchronizing cross-border digital payment systems, and systematically dismantling non-tariff barriers.
[SPEAKER_00]: 50 African nations have signed, ratified, onto a regional integration that will define the path to economic resilience and prosperity on this continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's worth noting that
[SPEAKER_00]: When we look at, for instance, the electric vehicles, the wind turbines, and the smart grids that are required for the 21st century economy, the fact that they depend on critical minerals like cobalt, like copper, like lithium, like manganese, and then put each part of them in the African soil.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think yesterday there was a meeting on this, and very important insights were revealed.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the historical paradigm of exporting raw materials and importing finished goods must conclude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa must prioritize the establishment of local processing and manufacturing hubs to build high-quality, job-rich industrial ecosystems that directly benefit all African citizens.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not going to be easy, but it's an imperative.
[SPEAKER_00]: It must be done.
[SPEAKER_00]: Furthermore, I think the world cannot really achieve its net zero carbon ambition without Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa is not merely participating in the green transition, it is setting the case.
[SPEAKER_00]: In Kenya, for example, over 90% of the national electricity grid is powered by renewable energy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And its national carbon registry now establishes international benchmarks for climate trading.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are proving that robust economic growth can be decoupled from carbon emissions, offering a viable model of green industrialization.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need this to be able to sustain the future and to fully realize these initiatives and to translate the structural advantages that the continent has into sustainable
[SPEAKER_00]: widespread prosperity i think governments must pivot decisively from crisis management to consistent policy implementation and i want to hear propose for a four-point action plan to anchor our developmental milestones none of them very surprising but first i think we must mobilize domestic capital to really close the development financing gap
[SPEAKER_00]: This can be done through comprehensive tax reforms, the digitalization of revenue collection, and of course the expansion of public-private partnerships.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa can really unlock substantial internal resources if we focus on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: We also have to look to our domestic institutional investors.
[SPEAKER_00]: African pension funds, the sovereign wealth funds.
[SPEAKER_00]: These we are finding
[SPEAKER_00]: significant amounts.
[SPEAKER_00]: The numbers range from 1.8 trillion to 4 trillion in assets.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yet, we know that only under 3% of this is currently allocated to local infrastructure.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is massive opportunity in front of the continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we have to use these projects to effectively crowd in domestic capital.
[SPEAKER_00]: The second is that we have to enforce strict industrial policies for local value addition.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to unleash Africa's tech-savvy, talented youth from Chad to Cameroon to South Africa to Nigeria to Botswana.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is so much talent.
[SPEAKER_00]: that is connected to today's digital tools that can be brought into the industrial space so that the exploitation for processed mineral ores and unrefined commodities ends.
[SPEAKER_00]: If international corporations require access to Africa's critical minerals or agricultural goods, they must establish processing facilities and manufacturing plants
[SPEAKER_00]: within the borders of Africa so that they can generate jobs and diversify Africa's economies, Africa must stop exporting its jobs and its livelihoods.
[SPEAKER_00]: The third is that we must prioritize cross-border infrastructure policies.
[SPEAKER_00]: The success of AFCFDA depends entirely on the efficiency of our ports, our roads, and our digital networks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sustained investment in regional transport links and harmonized digital payment platforms is essential to reduce transactional costs, to lower inflation, and to protect our economies from external disruptions.
[SPEAKER_00]: The fourth and last is that we have to systematically reform educational curricula to focus on STEM disciplines.
[SPEAKER_00]: and vocational training.
[SPEAKER_00]: The demographic dividend can only really be realized if our youth are equipped with the technical skills that are required by a modern industrial economy.
[SPEAKER_00]: We must train the engineers, scientists, and digital entrepreneurs who will develop local solutions to global challenges.
[SPEAKER_00]: Excellencies distinguish best.
[SPEAKER_00]: Global economic shocks right now are formidable, but they are not insurmountable.
[SPEAKER_00]: The current global architecture was built without Africa, but the future architecture cannot survive without Africa.
[SPEAKER_00]: The shift toward the multipolar world is an invitation for Africa to take its rightful seat at the global economic table.
[SPEAKER_00]: not as a beneficiary of aid, but as an indispensable partner in progress and an engine of global growth.
[SPEAKER_00]: And as we deliberate over the next few days, let us embrace the boldness and the courage that this historical moment demands.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is both personal and professional for some of us who have grown up on this continent.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let us remember the wisdom perfectly captured by the beautiful Ashanti Ova.
[SPEAKER_00]: One falls who spoils a thousand trees.
[SPEAKER_00]: One finger cannot catch a flea.
[SPEAKER_00]: A single African nation, acting in isolation, cannot withstand the geopolitical weight and the shifts of a fragmented world.
[SPEAKER_00]: But together,
[SPEAKER_00]: acting as a synchronized, integrated, continental block.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is no social economic barrier that we cannot break, and no future that we cannot build.
[SPEAKER_00]: And as I have now come to adopt, I think it is Africa's time, but on Africa's terms.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.